trouver une sortie de crise à tout prix
l'objet leur réunion entre une dizaine
d'élus locaux yvelinois réunis à l'hôtel
de ville de saint cyr l'école ce jeudi
soir elle fait suite à la décision du
prestataire vert-marine de fermer
provisoirement cinq de ces piscines dans
les yvelines la raison invoquée par ce
délégataire l'augmentation du coût de
l'énergie cette façon de mettre au pied
du mur alors que dans la discussion on
apprend que ben déjà en juin on était à
euros le méga kilowattheure alors qu'on
est normalement dans les 80 95 qu'en
juillet on était déjà à 500 un bon
partenariat aurait aurait impliqué qu'on
soit à alerter
bien en amont face à cette crise
énergétique majeure la mairie de saint
cyr l'école évoquent la possibilité
d'une mise en hivernage de sa piscine en
attendant une baisse des coûts de
l'énergie ça va prendre un petit moment
c'est peut-être c'est peut-être aussi
une solution palliative
avec des mesures européennes
gouvernementales qui vont nous aider à
pouvoir reprendre une activité
c'est une possibilité une inquiétude
autour des piscines qui laisse craindre
la fermeture d'autres équipements
publics je vous rappelle que grand
nombre de nos cantines sont en
délégation de service public et je pense
très sincèrement que l'acte 1 ct piscine
l'acte de ce sera les cantines et les
restaurations scolaires qui eux aussi
font face à des dépenses beaucoup plus
importantes que prévu versailles espère
une réouverture prochaine de sa piscine
mont boron la ville à négocier les
tarifs avantageux pour la consommation
énergétique de sa structure son objectif
est ensuite de revendre cette énergie à
vert marine nous allons faire bénéficier
la piscine du coup que nous avons
négocié nous avec nos deux syndicats
syndicats gazés et syndicats
d'électricité qui sont des goûts que
nous aurons nous négocier jusqu'à la fin
l'année qui sont moins élevés que ceux
que paie vert-marine la principale piste
de sortie de crise serait la mise en
place du fonds de soutien prévues par
l'état un bouclier destiné à soutenir
des entreprises très consommatrices
d'énergie face à la hausse
exceptionnelle des prix